BALAJI SIVAGANESAN: Have you
ever wondered of loading data
from Cloud Storage to Bigtable
using the power of Spark
by just passing some arguments?
Stay tuned.
This is Balaji.
I'm a Cloud Migration
Consultant with Google Cloud.
Dataproc templates
are an effort to solve
simple but large inflow
data tasks including
data import, export,
backup, restore,
and bulk AP operations.
The technology under
the hood, which
makes these operations
possible is the serverless part
functionality based on
Google Cloud's data hub.
Without having to create
them from scratch,
we can run typical use
cases on dataproc serverless
using Java and Python,
thanks to dataproc templates.
With the help of
these templates,
we can simply customize
under common Spark workloads.
Now we'll focus on GCS to
Bigtable Java template.
This template is written in
Spark which is open source
and can be customizable based on
the requirements from the user.
These are driven
by configurations
and are ready to use.
This offers the user
the power of Spark
and customizing for advanced
use cases is super cool.
One of the common
[INAUDIBLE] tasks
is to load data from
GCS to a low latency
database like Bigtable which
can power up any UI or real time
query platforms.
This template supports CSV,
Parquet, and Avro file formats.
These templates are ready
to use powered workloads,
and they can be altered with
connection parameters for use
cases with identical
requirements
and the development can
be completed in no time.
Here's the flow
of data in the GCS
to Bigtable dataproc template.
The source is the
GCS storage, which
holds the file to be loaded into
Bigtable in a storage bucket
inside a specific folder.
As of now, the template
supports loading
of CSV packet and out of files.
The file has to be
uploaded in a folder,
and the exact location has
to be passed as an argument.
Unlike other storage things,
Bigtable is quite different.
It is known for its low
latency performance,
and the overall
query performance
depends on the row key.
The data is stored as
column or storage format,
and each row has
its unique row key.
The beauty of this NoSQL lies
in its columnar axis of data.
So each column can alone be
accessed with its row key,
column family, and column name.
[INAUDIBLE] the goal
of this template
lies the power of Spark
provided by dataproc serverless.
It accesses the data in GCS and
loads the data in a [INAUDIBLE]
at a much faster
pace as it's driven
by the number of workloads
which are handled internally
by dataproc serverless.
Once the batch job is
started, the data serverless
looks into the
job configuration,
and its starts
the Spark session.
Right now there is no logic
written for any transformation.
It just loads the data
into big tables from GCS.
But in case of any
enhancements required,
it can be carried
out in no time.
Here is a sample
CSV file and how
it gets loaded into Bigtable.
As the row key
needs to be unique,
the first column in the CSV
file is taken as the row key,
and it gets loaded.
Further, the header details
are taken automatically
as the schema.
The column family
is specifically
passed as an argument.
As we see, the
various values gets
loaded as columns under
the given column family,
and the first column of the
given row is the row key.
Here is a sample
Avro file and how
it gets loaded into Bigtable.
From the input, we can see the
schema has a timestamp, tweet,
and the user name.
Since the username is the
first level value in the input,
that's taken as the row key.
The various values
gets loaded as columns
under the given column family.
The column names gets populated
automatically from the schema.
Here is a sample
packet file and how
it gets loaded into Bigtable.
From the input, we can see
the schema has continent
and the country array.
The continent is
the first value,
and it gets loaded
as the row key.
And the array of countries
gets loaded as a single value.
Further, there are two
rows with the same row key.
So it gets loaded
as two separate set
of columns under the same row
key, as it has to be unique.
In the previous
video, you would have
seen it's a three-step
process to execute.
First, the clone the repository
get authentication credentials,
and to execute the template.
Now let's focus
on the third part,
and how to execute the template.
First, create the GCS bucket,
then the input folder,
and upload the required
file into that folder.
Doing this in a console
is the most preferred one.
Next, create the
Bigtable instance
if it's already not
available in the cluster.
Then within the instance,
create the Bigtable table
with the required column family.
This column family has to
be passed in the arguments.
Set the configuration
parameters like the GCP project,
region of execution, and
the GCP staging location
for internal use to upload the
jars and temporary storage.
Then pass the arguments
and execute the template.
This is to Bigtable Java,
post which the batch Spark
job has to be monitored.
Here are the list
of arguments that
needs to be passed while
executing the template.
The major ones are the location
of the input file, the details
of the Bigtable instance, the
table name, and the column
family.
The respective project
tallies of the GCS storage
and the Bigtable also
needs to be passed.
Here are the commands used
to execute the template.
The ones in red shows the
configuration parameters
that needs to be set one
time during the session.
The start script will
trigger the template,
and the name of the template
has to be given along
with the required arguments.
Once this is submitted, it
builds the jar, copies to GCS,
and then triggers a batch job
in the dataproc serverless.
In this section, we will
cover hands-on on the GCS
to Bigtable template.
First, we will start
with the Cloud Shell,
and after
authentication is done,
let's clone the dataproc
template repository
into the Cloud Shell.
Then let's traverse
into the folder,
check the branch details
using the key status,
ensure that we are
in the main folder.
Let's ensure that we
have the required input
files in the input
folder of the GCS packet.
For instance, let's take a
CSV, Avro, and packet file.
Let's see how the input CSV
file us-states2 looks like.
It is a header and some record.
So we can enter into
the Bigtable instance
in a Bigtable, and let's create
a table if it doesn't exist.
For now, use the table bus-data.
Please note that
the column family
needs to be given correctly
while creating the table.
Now let's see the contents
of the bus data table.
You can see there is
no data in the table.
You would proceed with the
configuration parameters
to set up the configuration
parameters like GCP project,
region, GCP staging location.
Once the basic
setup is done, next
is our template
specific processes.
Populate the required documents
for running the template
like the location of
the input file in GCS,
expand, then the details on
the Bigtable table instance,
and the column family.
Copy the whole command for
executing the template.
And the logs of the Spark
job execution are shown here.
Once the job gets
completed, it clearly
provides the details
of the completed
job along with the
additional details.
The data from UI
shows the logs along
with the number of
executables that
are running in the back end.
In case, if we need to
view the detailed worker
level logs from Spark, it can be
seen from the view log section.
Now let's check how the data
were loaded into the Bigtable.
In our input we have
two records that we
can see that two records got
inserted into the Bigtable.
As shown in the
example previously,
we can see the schema got
updated into the column
names automatically.
With this, we are coming to
an end for the demo of GCS
to Bigtable template.
We are happy to seek
your feedback, queries,
and solutions based on
your requirements and usage
of these templates.
Please feel free to reach
us at Dataproc templates
support
external@Googlegroups.com.
Cheers.
Have a great day.